Weltpremiere!
…..oder besser Mondpremiere!
Zum ersten Mal überhaupt wird eine Mondsonde
auf der Rückseite des Mondes landen!
Es wird eine chinesische Sonde sein.
Was wird sie dort vorfinden?
Es gibt Verschwöriungstheorien nach denen
dort Städte, Wälder und Seen gäbe.
Und natürlich Hitler, verjüngt durch Alientechnologie,
wohnt.
Aber mindestens so verrückt ist das: Haaameer!
Eine halbe Million Abos.
Oh man, wenn mir das einer gesagt hätte als
ich 2013 mit Wissenschaftsvideos angefangen
habe.
Ich hätte es nicht für möglich gehalten.
Extrem serious Stuff und für den interessieren
sich 500tausend Menschen?
Verrückt!
Und jetzt alles über die chinesische Mondsonde.
Clixoom Science & Fiction.
Hier gibt es täglich spannende Science Videos.
Abonniert den Kanal.
Nur dann verpasst ihr kein Video!
Los geht‘s!
Herzlich willkommen.
Heute von der CCXP, der größten Comic Con
der Welt.
Die gibt es im Juni auch bei uns in Deutschland
in Köln.
Und das hier hinter mir ist das Raumschiff
aus Men in Black.
Bald in den Kinos.
Und das Raumschiff gibt es hier zum ersten
Mal naja zu sehen ist übertrieben.
Weltpremiere also hier in gewissem Maße.
Der Mann ist auch nicht tot zu kriegen.
Hitler auf der Rückseite des Mondes, lebend?
Städte, Wälder und Seen?
Oh man.
Also da kann ich schon mal entwarnen.
Das wird die Sonde dort auf keinen Fall finden.
Aber zum ersten Mal wird eine Sonde dort landen.
Bisher haben es alle Weltraumnationen gescheut
auf der Rückseite zu landen, weil das mit
deutlich erhöhtem Aufwand verbunden ist.
Denn nicht nur dieser Lander muss zum Mond
geschickt werden, sondern auch ein Mondsatellit
als Relaisstation, um die Signale an die Erde
zu senden.
Denn ein solcher Lander kann von der Rückseite
nicht direkt senden, weil der Mond ja dazwischen
ist.
Das geht nur über einen Satelliten, der von
der Erde aus gesehen werden kann und vom Lander,
quasi über Eck wird dann gesendet.
Allerdings wird es zumindest keine Überraschungen
zu SEHEN geben.
Denn die Mondrückseite wurde bereits 1959
von der russischen Mondsonde Lunik 3 aufgenommen.
Hier eine neuere Aufnahme des Lunar Reconnaissance
Orbiters von der Mondrückseite aus dem Jahr
2009.
Also schonmal keine Städte, keine Wälder
und keine Seen.
Der Lunar Reconnaissance Orbiter ist übrigens
auch die Sonde, die alle Apollo Landeplätze
fotografiert hat.
Das nur an alle Mondlandungsskeptiker.
Jetzt also eine chinesische Mondsonde, die
zum ersten Mal auf der Rückseite landet:
Chang‘e 4.
In gut einem Monat wird sie nach dem Start
jetzt dort im Aitken-Krater landen.
Nach dem Touchdown wir eine Roboterfahrzeug
den Lander verlassen und die Umgebung untersuchen.
Neben diversen Messgeräten ist auch eine
Panoramakamera an Bord.
Zusätzlich ist auch ein kleines Gewächshaus
mit auf dem Mond und es wird getestet, wie
Pflanzen bei der niedrigen Gravitation des
Mondes wachsen.
Achja: Kleine Info am Rande.
Wer durch das Pink Floyd-Album „Dark Side
of th Moon konspiriert ist zu glauben, dass
die Rückseite des Mondes dunkel ist.
Immer wenn wir hier auf der Erde Vollmond
haben, der Mond also dunkel ist, ist Rückseite
hell und Umgekehrt.
Jede Seite des Mondes ist also gleich hell,
so dass das Licht für ein solches Experiment
mehr als ausreichend ist.
Wir können also auf die Ergebnisse gespannt
sein.
Hier werden wir euch natürlich darüber informieren.
Wenn ihr also dazu und zu allen anderen Themen
kein Video verpassen wollt, dann abonniert
auch den englischen Kanal von Clixoom.
Denn auch da gibt es immer öfter Videopremieren.
Dafür einfach hier klicken.
Und hier geht es weiter mit: What do aliens
look like?
Ich freue mich auf euch auch auf dem englischen
Kanal!
See you soon, stay tuned!